hey what's up my name's samuel lees i am
a property investor
and right now i'm gonna be answering
your property investment questions
so any questions that you've got a tool
that might be holding you back
comment them below as a question and i
will do my very best to answer those
questions
next week but right now i'm going to be
answering some of the questions that we
had from the previous week
if you enjoy my videos do me a favor hit
the like button
go on you always do it don't not do it
now hit the like button
also subscribe turn the notification
bell on and when i'm answering questions
it might be that i answer someone's
question it kind of gives you an
offshoot of a question
or your brain starts ticking comment
below okay and we can dialogue
on my next q a video but right now we've
got jordan jordan says
i'm 18 19 sorry from essex
i've recently completed on a level three
diploma in plumbing but i'm looking to
get into property with intentions to do
something like brr
through a limited company any
suggestions on how to start a limited
company for property
or could i do it through a plumbing
company if i had one
so firstly jordan congratulations sounds
like you're a smart guy a lot of money
in plumbing i used to want to be a
plumber that was what i
that was my dream job and i became a
property investor
instead which i think is better if
you're wanting to
stop buying properties through a company
my advice jordan would be to set up a
brand new company
specifically for property investment it
keeps it separate
limited liability and also it's cleaner
uh you'll actually find it probably
easier to get a mortgage through a brand
new company that you can be a guarantor
of
as opposed to having a company that's
already got a bit of accounts and i just
have a brand new one
you'll find that'll be better but of
course this is not tax advice
i'm just a property investor i'm not a
tax advisor
so speak to an accountant but that would
be what i would probably suggest hope
that helps
callum buchanan i'm 20. i've got 25
grand saved
i want to get into property good
20 with 25 grand very very good what do
you recommend is it possible to buy a
buy to let with 25 grand i appreciate it
calum it is possible if you've got 25
grand
typically you need to put down about 25
deposit
so you could buy a hundred thousand
pound house but that doesn't take into
account
stamp duty legal fees so realistically
you're probably only going to be able to
buy an 80 000 pound house
which is probably going to rent out for
about 400
maybe if you're lucky 500 pounds a month
which after
mortgage your mortgage interest payments
and
also management and voids and
maintenance you're probably going to be
left with a profit of around about 200
maybe at best 300 pounds a month so
yes you can you'll be on the ladder
you'll be making a couple hundred pound
a month or so
however it might be better depending on
what your long-term goals are
to use that money and put it into
starting a property
business like rent to rent
something where you can start
controlling properties because you can
make
500 a thousand pounds per month from one
property that you don't even own
and you could get multiple of those for
you 25 grand which is going to be
life-changing
and then use the profits to put into
your own portfolio
so yes you can the question is should
you perhaps
not hope that helps all right joshua
morrison
what is the percentage yield you base
your rental properties on
i've heard between 10 and 15 is the best
possible yield but how realistic is that
number from your experience
okay so firstly we don't do yield okay
we do return on investment yield
is if you buy a house for 100 grand and
you rent it out for
10 grand a year that's a 10 yield
but yield is irrelevant because it
doesn't matter what the rent is it
doesn't matter what the purchase price
was
what really matters is what did you put
in and what are you getting back
so in the last example we said you could
put in 25 grand
and you could get back profit of about
250 pounds a month
okay that's what matters not yield
return on cash on cash
investment you need to understand the
differences i have done a previous video
about the difference between yield and
return on investment i'd suggest you to
check it out i'll put it as a little
card
above my head which you can click on so
if you do want to do yield
you'll pre you'll probably find that the
higher the yield the more risky the
investment is
so if it's in really cheap areas you are
not going to get long-term leases
also you can make the yield look really
good for example on a hmo
the yield looks great because the rate's
really high but it doesn't take into
account
account bills utilities wi-fi so
that's why return on investment is much
better hope that helps but
yeah 10 to 15 yield is probably about
top end
yes return on investment could be much
higher
ris shar been following a long time i've
invested i've been investing for a while
now
if you had 150 000 pounds more to invest
would you buy five or six houses and
rent them out or would you buy one big
investment what would you advise to do
i would buy one big investment okay if
you're already investing in properties
you don't want to grow a big portfolio
this way
you want to every deal that you do go
bigger and bigger and bigger because a
big deal and a small deal take just as
much energy
so the difference between big deals and
small deals is big deals have just extra
zeros on the end
why not why not just do one deal that's
10 times the size 10 times the profits
10 times
rather than buying 10 little properties
because then you've got to do the
paperwork 10 times get 10 management
companies you've got 10 lots of tenants
make sense all right next stuart
trevorlock just a small question what
your thoughts on
lloyd's bank becoming landlords or
trying to become landlords is this a
good or bad thing
as they have an unlimited amount of
money to purchase properties looking
forward
to the feedback so you're threatened by
lloyd's bank
because you're saying they've got an
unlimited amount of money listen
listen stuart you've got an unlimited
amount of money as well
all lloyd's bank are doing is they're
saying to people hey
put your money with us they're
advertising
they've got the black horse going around
the whole country up and down on the
billboards
they're going oh everybody put your
money with us
they're taking people's money they're
keeping it safe
if lloyd's went bust you'd only get back
86 grand approximately and the rest will
be squandered and gone
they're using your money and they're
investing it openly
proudly you can do the same
there's an unlimited amount of money in
the world
they're printing billions there's
billions and billions of pounds of cash
going around right now that didn't exist
12 months ago
so you can do the same i don't care that
lloyds are doing it
all right lin's join last question okay
if you join the video hit like
last question i'm a builder and a
landlord with a handful of properties
but i'm about to undertake a new build
with a gdv gross development value of
around three hundred thousand pounds
my question is would you get some trendy
cad images drawn up and then get the
property on the market as it comes out
the ground on a fixed price
so as to sell fast or get the project
completed hopefully by being able to
achieve a higher price
i'd market it before you sell it okay i
would i would get cgi images
computer generated images and what it's
going to look like
stick it on right move with a nice
high-end agent
and i'd sell it before it's even
finished folks i hope you enjoyed it
i'm going to see you next time thanks
for watching peace